percées de l'après-midi.
Alternant soleil. Ça rest vente
- Vous, s un grand
météorologue de carrière,
Pascal, mais c'est votre
première apparition,
je crois, officielle
à la télévision.
Étiez-vous un peu énervé?
- Bien, je suis pas mal énervé.
En fait, j'ai des papillons
dans l'estomac.
On en prend quand même
des groses belleses belleses bes
grosses truites.
C'est un petit peu comme
avec la 5nzn9 Au début,
on avait des petites gouttes
comme ça, on est rendu avecdes !
Des grosses, grosses!
Regardez-moi ça comment ça
tombe! On est carrément trempés.
ÈVE CHRISTIAN,
météorologue, ICI Première
- Te rappelles-tu que c'est
à cause de ma bedaine que
tu es rentré à Radio-Canada,
quand j'ai eu ma première fille.
Écoute, tu as fait une carrière
écoeurante. Tu as droit à
ta retraite. Je t'en souhaite
toute une, amu9e-t==t
Salut Pascal!
VÉRONIQUE MAYRAND, chroniqueuse
météo, ICI Première
- Un petit mot pour te dire
vraiment un grand merci.
Je te dois beaucoup, tu as été
un véritable mentor pour moi.
Merci pour tout ce que tu
m'as appris. J'ai été choyée
de te côtoyer pees
ces années.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Moi, j'étais un fanatique de
Batman. J'étais scotché devant
la télé; ouais Batman!
- On feru Batman eu Batman eu Bt
Robin nous, non?
- Oui. Qui serait Batman?
- Je me demande...
(rires)
- Ah!
(rires)WALDIR DWALDIR DWALDIR D,
météorologue, ICI Télé
- Que ton sens de l'humour
reste quand@même bien présent,
que ce soit en ondes, mais aussi
à l'extérieur. Ta passionpour li
que la musique classique et tes
qualités en tant que
météorologue hors pair.
Sache que tu es une source
d'inspiration très prononcée
pour moi. Et pour cela,
je t'en remercie.
JULIE JASMINE BOUDREAU,
chroniqueuse météo, ICI Télé
- Ce côté très relax que tu as,
justement, de raconter la mé
l'espèce de coolitude
de Pascal Yiacouvakis. Je te
remercie de m'avoir transmis ça.
On est en route pour
facilement 25 pour la région
métropolitaine.
- Avec toute cette pluie qui
est tombée, il en est tombée
beaucoup, il faut le dire.
- Oui, oui. À Montréal, on a
reçu 80 mm de pluie.
Je voulais voir ce qu'on a
reçu, jere ça tout
de suite. Vous voyez, le premier
lit d'en bas, c'est le grésil et
au-dessus, il y a une couche de
glace, le verglas. Et on attend
à peu près 10 à 20 mm de verglas
supplémentaire.
- C'est de l'eau, là,
c'est beaucoup d'eau.
- Là c
verglaçante. Vous le voyez,
donc c'est de la pluie
verglaçante mêlée à du grésil.
Tantôt, il y avait plus de
grésil que de pluie verglaçante.
de pluie
verglaçante que de grésil.
- Alors, C'est mauvais signe,
ça?
- C'est très, très mauvais
signe.
DEROME,DEROME,DEROME,DEROME,DER,
ex-animateur, "Le Téléjournal"
- Bonsoir Pascal,
tu as eu une carrière
absolument exemplaire.
Une maîtrise exceptionnelleiencs
toujours nuancé, accessible,
direct, bref, ce sont là
des ingrédients de la
communication et tu les possèdes
tous. Et puis, je gardece très,r
des moments où nous avons
travaillé, pas seulement au
moment du verglas,
fait, à chaque fois, c'était
plein de soleil. Alors,
qu'est-ce que je te souhaite?
Je te souhaite du bonheur,
beaucoup de bonheur, du plaisir.
Et merci pour ta très grande
contribution.
Avec mon amitié, Pascal.
- (en choeur)
Bonne retraite Pascal!
- Waouh, carrière exceptionnelle
Pascal.
- Merci.
- Tu es Pascal un grand
vulgarisateur scientifique. Tu
fais parti de ça. Sois fié.
Profites-en et merci, au nom de
toute l'équipe, d'avoir su nous
expliquer les affaires pas mal
compliquées.
- J'ai essayé. Ça c'est mon côté